(upbeat techno music)
- Welcome to episode 35
of the Addy Hour Podcast.
For those of you who've been listening
and watching regularly,
you know it's been a while
since we released an episode,
so I'm really excited to release
this first episode of 2023.
And I'm also excited to let you know
that we'll be back to
regularly scheduled episodes
where you'll be seeing
new Addy Hour episodes
every other week for the months coming up.
Now in this first episode,
I'm really excited to introduce and talk
about a topic of burnout,
which might sound like a strange place
to start for the new year,
but I think it's a topic
that's really relevant
to many of us in so
many different spheres.
But before we get there,
did want to make a quick
announcement to all of you.
I actually started a
newsletter a couple weeks back
and wanted to make sure
that you all know about that.
If you wanna check it out,
you can find it on Substack.
It's called the Addy Minute Newsletter.
And if you're looking for it,
just type into your browser,
N-I-I-A-D-D-Y.substack,
that's S-U-B-S-T-A-C-K.com,
and you'll be able to
find that newsletter.
Definitely encourage you to check it out.
In the newsletter, I'm gonna be talking
about aspects of my journey.
Also gonna be sharing mental wellness tips
with all of you, and also talking about
some of the upcoming podcast episodes
and engaging in further conversations
around these episodes.
It'll also be an opportunity for you all
to engage with me and to also share ideas
and comments and questions
that you'd like me to
ask our podcast guests.
So definitely encourage
you to check it out.
And with that, just wanna go ahead
and let you all know about the two guests
that are coming on.
We're actually gonna do
something a little bit different
because we weren't able to get both guests
on the same episode at the same time
so we're actually going to
release back to back episodes.
I think you all are
really going to enjoy it.
We have guests from two different spheres
and two different walks of life
who are gonna talk about this aspect
of burnout and really
trying to help us think
about ways to thrive.
So with that, I did want to go ahead
and give a quick
introduction to both guests.
The first guest that we'll be joining
for the episode today
is Dr. Christine Pfund,
who is a scientist with the Washington,
or Wisconsin, sorry,
with the Wisconsin Center
for Education Research
and the Department of Medicine
at the University of Wisconsin-Madison.
Dr. Pfund, as I mentioned, is a scientist.
She earned her PhD in cellular
and molecular biology.
She followed that by postdoctoral research
as a plant and plant pathology,
but then shifted for almost a decade,
was a co-director of the,
or an associate director
of the Delta Program in
Research, Teaching, and Learning,
and also co-director of
the Wisconsin Program
for Scientific Teaching.
And there she really helped
to train future faculty
to become better and
more effective teachers.
Dr. Pfund also led initiatives
and directed national
programs around mentoring,
which is where many of those of you
in academic spaces may have heard of her.
She was one of the
co-authors of the original
Entering Mentoring curriculum.
And she's also co-authored a lot of papers
around mentorship.
She directs the National
Research Mentoring Network
and also the newly established Center
for the Improvement of Mentored
Experience in Research.
So again, someone who
has been deeply invested
in mentoring over the years
and also co-authored an article
about burnout in mentorship.
So that's the topic of our conversation
and something that I think
will be very enriching
for all of us.
Again, we're gonna release
episodes back to back.
So next week we'll be
bringing on a second guest
who is also going to talk
about this aspect of burnout,
but talking about this from
the perspective of a pastor.
So thinking about service roles of pastors
and those in different
ministry, opportunities,
and occupations and
different faith traditions.
But for that episode, we're
gonna have the privilege
of welcoming Dr. David Ireland.
Dr. Ireland is the founder and lead pastor
of Christ Church which is a 10,000 member
multi-site congregation
in North New Jersey
that represents over 70 nationalities.
So in that conversation,
we obviously talk a lot
about leadership as well.
Dr. Ireland is a former
diversity consultant for the NBA.
He's also led chapel services
with New York Giants,
the New York Jets, and at the US Pentagon.
He's the author of over 25 books,
including "Raising a Child Who Prays."
And he is someone who speaks in a lot
of different spheres and areas of impact,
has traveled and spoken in over 75 nations
as someone who has tremendous impact.
He holds graduate degrees
in engineering, theology,
organizational leadership,
and social innovation.
Having also completed post-doctoral work
at the University of Pennsylvania
and at the University of
Cambridge and England.
So I know you all are
going to definitely enjoy
that conversation that's
coming up one week from today.
But with that, we're gonna go ahead
and jump into episode 35.
Thanks again for being here,
I hope you all enjoy this conversation.
(lively techno music)
Well, it's my pleasure
to be able to lead off
this conversation today.
As you heard in the introduction,
we're doing something a
little bit different today
since both of our guests
weren't able to be
at the recording at the same time.
But we thought that just
both of their perspectives
would be really important
to share with you.
So this is gonna be a little
bit of an experiment for us,
but I think they'll still be
able to riff off of one another
even though they're
not actually physically
in the same Zoom room at the same time.
But it's my absolute pleasure to welcome
Dr. Christine Pfund to
the Addy Hour Podcast.
Thank you so much for being here.
- So glad to be here.
Really appreciate the invitation.
- Of course.
And I've heard your name for years.
We finally got the chance to interact
a couple months ago in an event.
And so in a lot of ways
it's nice to be able to
engage in this work together just
with all that you've
done around mentorship
and around this topic of burnout
as we'll talk about today.
So definitely appreciate you being here
and even taking the
time to be here with us.
Not to make a bad joke,
but I hope that as you get these requests
like I have made today,
this does not add to the
likelihood susceptibility
of the burnout, but I guess we
can get into that as well as we talk.
- Yeah, we'll definitely get into that.
- So before we go there, my listeners know
and you know that I like to just check in
with people and see how they're
doing at this point in time.
So we're still in the
early phases of 2023.
So just wanted to ask how you're doing
in the midst of that with everything
that you juggle and balance
on a day-to-day basis
and just what your outlook
is for the year ahead.
- Yeah, thanks for asking.
Yeah, I'm doing really well.
I'm still riding that high of the holidays
which were filled with lots of
family and friends and games
and laughter and food,
probably a little bit too much food.
And yeah, and feeling like
getting to ease into things.
And it's been busy, but coming from a
place of having a good rest,
a lot of good energizing interactions.
And even coming in today
after Martin Luther
King holiday yesterday,
which included a little
bit less stress schedule,
a little time to sleep in,
little time to reflect,
a little time to listen to some speakers
and have some conversations with friends.
So yeah, I'm joining you
in a really grounded,
centered place today.
How about you?
How are you doing today?
- I'd say very similar.
And I appreciate you asking that question.
So in the same way,
it's been nice just to have
some time to slow down,
to pause, especially with
the Martin Luther King Jr.
Holiday you mentioned too,
which is always a mixture of the pausing
and the reflection and
just thinking about things
where we've improved,
things where we still have work to do.
But again, just as I
think very similar to you,
it's the beginning of the year,
things haven't really picked up
at the pace that they often do,
although I think that's
starting in the week ahead.
So for me, I'm actually
just trying to savor that.
And full disclosure, also
trying to have a mindset
where I can actually slow down,
even with all the pressures
and tasks that have to be done,
but just to actually
slow down, to make room,
to actually be present in
the moment with all those,
and to actually be more
generative in the work that I do,
or in interactions that I have,
whether that's with
colleagues or with students
or with family members.
So I'd say for me, I'm kind of,
you can probably hear it in my voice.
I'm still in that pseudo reflective place
and just thinking about trying to put
some good practices into place
in the year ahead so that when things
actually do pick up, that I
can still kind of have this
mode of peace and reflection
in the midst of work
as I'm going through it.
So that may have been too
much of an academic type
of answer, but that's
where I'm at at the moment.
- Well, yeah, I think I hear us both kind
of just speaking into, we're breathing,
I definitely I'm headed,
actually made this trip yet last year,
at the end of January, I
kind of flipped my time off.
And actually on Friday,
headed back to Mexico
to do some scuba diving.
And I only bring it up here
because last year when I went,
if you've scuba dived,
you know that if you get
to a neutral buoyancy,
then you can control
actually how your body moves
simply by how deep you breathe in
and how much you let the air out,
you become buoyant.
So just bringing that air into your lungs
will raise you up and blowing it out
will make you sink a little.
And I just mentioned
it because when I came,
I went back, I haven't
dove in a couple years
and I came out of the water and I thought,
oh, I had forgotten how to breathe.
And I've been thinking
about that all year.
And when I get stressed,
I just kind of imagine myself scuba diving
and having that ability to breathe
and control everything for your breath,
which I know a lot of
yogis also experience.
And so I was just thinking yesterday,
oh, I'm gonna retap into my need
to think about breathing very concretely
when I'm under the water next week.
- That's great.
Well, I appreciate you sharing that.
And I think, and so I mean,
with these things that we
can apply from that as well,
just going into the air and again,
just being in this place.
So that's a great, yeah.
I don't know if I'll be
scuba diving anytime soon.
- I highly recommend.
It was one of my dreams.
I was terrified to learn.
I was the worst student ever.
Everything that could go wrong went wrong.
And yet it's become something
that I absolutely love to do.
But it took a lot of learning.
I had a lot of fears to overcome.
- Wow, well that's great to hear.
I mean, so I'm trying not to
parallel this to the podcast,
but there's so many things
in what you just said,
even about resilience or
about enduring something
that's painful and challenging
and what the reward is on the other side.
So, okay, I won't go too far,
but just to throw those out there.
- Go ahead, peel the
onion layers if you want.
- I can go off on that for
quite a bit in a good way.
But again, I actually just appreciate you
asking how I'm doing at
this point in time too.
So it's refreshing to be
able to have that level
of conversation.
I think that candor has
become more commonplace
and I'm hoping that actually sticks
in some of those circles that we move in.
So definitely something that I appreciate.
Other thing that I was gonna do,
just to pivot a little bit,
because one of the things
that you're known for,
obviously for those who
are familiar with you
and for those who aren't
to introduce is mentorship
and something that you spent a lot of time
really investing in as a mentor
and as a trainer of mentors, so to speak.
So I was curious if you'd be able to share
a little bit about how
you got into that work,
and then eventually we'll tie in
how the mentorship and burnout
piece came about as well.
- Sure. Yeah.
Thanks for asking.
Yeah, so my college and
post-college degrees
are in biology.
So specifically I have a PhD
actually in cell molecular biology,
which means I had lots of opportunities
to be mentored in my
quest to be a scientist.
So I'll right out of the gate say
I had lots of amazing mentors.
Not everybody was perfect,
and those ended up being incredible
learning experiences along the way.
I don't actually think
any mentor can be perfect,
but I think as a trainee,
sometimes we expect that,
I'm not sure what
perfection is in mentorship,
but that's something we can unpack too.
But along the way,
especially in graduate school
and my post-graduate work,
I just kept finding
myself more and more drawn
to questions around how
scientists were trained
to do things outside, in my case,
the research biology research laboratory
to do the other work
they were called to do
if they were to go on as faculty
or in any kind of leadership.
And these would include roles in teaching
and in mentoring other folks.
And the ability to teach and mentor
has huge impacts on those
with whom they work,
but very few scientists
are formally trained
how to do either.
And so that became very
much a point of interest
and fascination for me.
And so over the last 18 years,
I've had this amazing
opportunity to investigate
in particular mentorship.
I also did a lot of work
in teaching and learning
but we'll focus on mentorship for today.
And that led to helping develop programs
to enhance mentorship.
And that led to developing
interventions or trainings
to help folks become better
mentors and better mentees.
And then that research bug in my head
really kept me talking to evaluators
and social scientists to understand
how those types of trainings work.
And then finding out that there were lots
of research questions we could ask about
what does it mean to be in an effective
research mentoring relationship?
What does it mean to have
a good working alliance
with someone?
What are the impacts of mentorship
and for who and in what context?
And so that's been
really the emergent work
over almost two decades.
And I've had, I'm not trained
to do any of those things
and have really learned on the job
from amazing mentors, really,
kind of coming full circle.
So I always like to say
that I'm a scientist
who started by studying microorganisms
and I ended up studying people.
- I think that's really well put.
And I appreciate the way you've
captured all those pieces.
Even the fact that you mentioned
that you weren't trained,
but that you did learn from mentors,
but then you've also now been invested
in the training itself and
the science of mentorship,
so to speak, and being able to bring
those two together.
And I think that's so important.
Just to share a personal story.
I remember when I first
started my position, again,
this is within an academic setting,
but this obviously applies
in lots of other ways.
But I do remember I was participating
in like in a local conference
and doing a session on mentorship,
but some of the other
more seasoned faculty
basically were thinking,
well, you're brand new.
What can you have to
share about mentorship?
As if it was something that people
just learned by osmosis.
And just because you're more senior,
that means you're a good mentor.
If you're a junior, then you
must not be a good mentor.
So, in some ways, real, and in many ways
just appreciate the emphasis
that you've put on that.
And I think similar to you,
even though I was junior at that point,
I had had really strong mentors
and was able to learn from them
and apply those things so much so
that people can weigh, oh,
you actually did have something to say
and to share with us as if that was
somehow not.
- How surprising, Right?
Yeah, I always love when
people are surprised.
Yeah, and I really think
early on in this work,
when we asked mentors how
they learned how to mentor,
we basically got two answers.
Either I learned from watching the mentors
that I thought were effective
and I like to try to do everything
they modeled or the opposite
whereas I had horrible mentors
and I'm trying to do
everything exactly counter
to what I experienced.
And then it was basically trial and error.
And even though every
mentoring relationship
is idiosyncratic, we
have to understand people
are individuals and have individual needs
and come from different
contexts and backgrounds.
There are some core
principles like communication
that really folks can
all, including ourselves,
always optimize and always be able
to enhance their toolbox.
- Yeah, I highly agree.
And even as you shared those two stories,
I mean one theme that jumps
out to me from both of those
is both of those were intentional.
People were either
intentionally trying to be
like someone or intentionally trying
to not be like someone else,
but had that intentionality
in how they moved forward.
And again, just in my experience,
and I'm sure in the work
that you've done too,
the fact that you have the training
the intentionality is
there, seems to be key.
Because again, that question now is asked
is almost as if
the person assumed that I hadn't thought
about mentorship because I was junior.
- Right, had it reflected on it.
One of my dear friends and colleagues
and also amazing scholar in this area,
Dr. Angela Byars-Winston,
who's also here at UW Madison,
she always says, and
we also try to echo in
all of our mentorship education,
is that it's not enough
to be well-intentioned,
you have to be intentional.
And I think to add to that,
And be intentional with tools and evidence
in your back pocket.
You don't come from a place
of not being informed.
And that doesn't mean
you have to necessarily
have read 50 books on mentorship,
but take a moment to reflect
on why you're doing things,
ask the people you're working with
if it's working for them.
Those are parts of being intentional too.
It's not just, I decided
I'm gonna lose weight
this year and I'm gonna focus on it.
It's like, well, why
hasn't that worked before?
And who's gonna help me?
There's a lot of components
to being intentional.
- Well, I appreciate you sharing that,
such wisdom in that,
and that such wisdom that
we can definitely apply
going forward.
And again, I mean, you're demonstrating
what you've already said at the beginning
of just how you've
taken and learned things
from so many different
people, from your colleagues,
and just incorporate that in
the work that you're doing.
So I appreciate that you're
practicing what you preach
in a lot of ways.
The other thing I know
that people are eager about
this episode is this
topic of burnout as well.
And I guess I'm segueing by saying,
practicing what you preach,
because for our listeners,
we'll also have another
guest who will be joining,
who is actually a pastor and a leader
who also has talked about
these aspects of burnout,
but then also mentorship and coaching
in different roles and those
who are in pastor roles
and in ministry.
So again, we've talked
about this intentionality
and moving things forward,
but there can also be extremes of that
and not even extremes,
and especially in service roles
when you're so invested in other people
that can easily lead
to a place of burnout.
So Chris, I was wondering
if you could just share
how the burnout topic even came up
within this realm of mentorship
and what brought that about?
'Cause I imagine it's something that's,
not just imagined, I know
it's always been there,
but not always talked about.
- Yeah, it's actually how the,
so we wrote a piece,
my colleagues and I, and I'll mention
who I'm talking about in a minute
for the Harvard Business
Review in last year.
And it's a funny story
actually, how it came to be.
So maybe I'll share a
little bit with listeners,
'cause I also think it's
about how things just happen
but you have to be looking for them.
There are four of us worked on this piece
for Harvard Business Review.
So Ruth Gotian and Chaveso
Cook and Brad Johnson.
And so Ruth is a chief learning officer
and assistant professor
at Weill Cornell Medicine in New York.
And then Chaveso goes by Chevy Cook,
he's actually a US Army Lieutenant Colonel
and he's at Fort Meade,
but he also runs this nonprofit
called Military Mentors.
And then Brad Johnson, he's actually
a professor of psychology
in the Department of
Leadership, Ethics, and Law
at the US Naval Academy.
And he also has an
position at John Hopkins.
These three folks have
been kind of what I'll call
in the science and practice
of mentorship world
for quite a while.
And they've written
different types of things
and they study different types of things
and as you can imagine,
just from hearing where they work.
And we've all known
about each other's work
and we've all been fans
of each other's work,
but we haven't been in the
same spaces necessarily.
And over the last about
four or five years,
we'd end up finding
ourselves in the same room,
but not all together.
So two of us would be at one thing
and then two of us would
be at something else.
And every time that would happen,
the group that was
physically together on Zoom
or physically together in
person or on Zoom would say,
oh, we have to write something together.
And each of the different folks
had written with each other.
So this happened again
in early spring 2022
is Chevy and I were at a meeting, he said,
"We have to write something together."
And I said, "Oh, well Ruth has been saying
we have to write something else together."
And then Brad was at this meeting too
and he is like, "Well, I
don't have a lot of time
but we should write something together."
So we finally all got on a Zoom call,
no idea what we were gonna write about.
Literally just said we
all admire each other,
we're all thinking in this space,
we should surely if we
got on a call together
we could come up with something
we should write together.
And so I like to share that part
because I think that from the outside
it sometimes looks like everything
is structured and we
came to a conversation
and you better show up
with a brilliant idea,
otherwise why would you show up?
No, we literally got on a call and said,
"All we wanna do is do something together.
We don't know what we should do."
And so we started talking
and everybody said,
"Oh yeah, it would be great
to write something together.
But I'm too busy.
I'm kind of burnt out.
I'm kind of tired."
You can see where this is going.
"Oh, wait a minute, maybe
I've been talking to mentors
and they've been talking
about being burnt out
and I'm kind of feeling burnt out."
And then Brad Johnson said,
"I've actually written a topic
about mentor self-care in 2018
and about how to avoid burnout."
And so really like within
an hour we had said,
"That's it, we've gotta
write something about
avoiding mentor burnout."
And we literally just set up a Google Doc
and we started throwing things in it.
And then we met like two more times
and we did the whole thing in a couple,
like several weeks.
And then fortuitously,
it turned out that Brad had a connection
at Harvard Business Review.
They were looking for an article.
So, you know, it just kind
of ha happens that way
in the networking.
But it really was interesting
because when we finished and we wrote it,
and we can talk more about
what's in the article
if you want,
we all said
that we felt really re-energized
after writing it
even though we had put
something new on our plate.
And you and I were joking
before we kind of started the podcast
as like, oh, I hope I didn't
like make you feel burnt out
because I asked you to do the podcast
or for you thinking you're
doing one more podcast.
But we realize that there is something
in just thinking about burnout
and thinking through why
am I feeling that way,
What things energize me,
what's drawing my energy away?
And this article energized us
that actually helped
us feel less burnt out
than when we decided to do it.
So that's just a little bit of kind of how
it actually all played out.
And it was a wonderful like thing to do
with three amazing colleagues
that we had all wanted
to do something together
and then we all felt better.
- Wow, that's amazing.
I mean, I appreciate hearing
how you all were attentive
to what you were experiencing
in that moment too.
I mean, just the fact of naming it
seems like it was so,
cathartic isn't the
right word, but just...
- Yeah, and then someone would say,
"This week I don't have any time."
And someone else would
say, "Well, I'll work,
I'll spend 30 minutes on it this week
and then I'll hand it off."
And so it became kind of the process
of like all the things we were saying
in the article of then saying,
"Wait, am I doing that?"
- Yeah. Yeah.
- Which is always a little bit scary.
I thought about when you
asked me to be a guest is
that the thing I was most nervous about
was not how many ums and not would I say
something that didn't sound smart,
or it was mostly if my
friends or colleagues or family listen it,
would they tell me that
I had been authentic
to how they were experiencing
me dealing burnout.
- Wow.
Yeah, that makes a lot of sense.
I guess it's that level in
a sense of accountability.
- Yeah, right.
Was I gonna get on and be like,
"Well here's how you avoid it."
And then they'd be like,
"Literally three weeks ago
you were so burnt out."
Just to be honest.
And I think that taking
time to just be honest
about what it means when we feel burnt out
has been really important.
I was thinking a lot about
since writing the article
and thinking about it,
I've done a lot better
job of querying burnout.
What does that mean,
when I say I'm burnt out,
or I hear someone say they're burnt out,
first I wanna validate
that in myself and others,
but also to say what
does that actually mean?
Does it mean I'm exhausted to the point
that I need to go sleep for three days?
Does it mean I'm actually
just irritated by everybody
asking me for something
and actually if I take a
walk, I'm gonna be okay?
Or am I really at a place of such burnout
that I'm being cynical,
I'm being inefficient in everything I do
'cause my mind's wandering
cause I can't focus.
But that's been really helpful
in listening for in myself and others
is when we say that just investigating it
a little bit.
- That's really good.
How have you helped people to do that?
I'm curious and even in a way
'cause I know you centered the article
kind of in the history of the term,
so I'm curious how you have
suggested that people apply that
to their own situations,
and then also based on
how they apply that,
how they actually move forward
to kind of move out of that
place of those different,
not tiers, but different modes of burnout.
- Yeah, and I'm certainly
not an expert in helping people.
Definitely not a therapist,
although my mother is one.
But I do think that, well
I could even say to you,
so the last time you felt really burnt out
is think about what you were feeling,
think about the weight of it.
How big did it feel?
Did it feel all consuming?
Was it only in certain contexts?
Was it every day?
Was it only when you were
dealing with certain issues
to try like to just
examine it a little bit.
So I think that it's not one specific way,
but to allow someone to explore,
tell me what that feels like,
tell me when that happens,
tell me about what you do
when you feel like that.
So that then we can kind of say, oh wow.
So it's sounding like
whenever you think about,
let's just use for example
the enormous weight of parental care
that you're engaged in,
that's where it's really feeling enormous
and that it's trickling
into all of your work,
but that is at its core
is where your burnout's coming from.
And so what could you do around that?
- Yeah, I think that's really helpful.
And I mean, even just
doing a mental exercise
as you were asking that and thinking about
getting back to even mentoring
all the different types
of mentoring roles that I have.
And if I had to say, oh
well I couldn't notice
some specific patterns
of certain types of roles
where there was more of a burnout feel
or feeling too spread
thin and thinking about,
well then I might not feel
like I have as much time
to respond to those things
or feeling more irritable
about those things.
So even in that exercise,
I think that's really helpful
to kind of piece through it
and think about in that
very pragmatic way.
And I'm also curious, as you wrote,
how do people respond to the article?
Because I could see it
going in different ways.
I could see it being
refreshing for people.
I could see sometimes
people being reactive to it,
maybe not maybe needing to hear it,
but not wanting to,
and not to put words in your mouth,
but those are just things
that kind of come to mind
as I think about people,
how people might have reacted.
But I'm curious what your experience was
and how people responded.
- Yeah, I think you hit
the nail on the head
is it's a little bit of everything.
So I think for some it
provided validation
for how they were feeling,
that they could say, yeah,
I know this mentoring work is important,
but it's exhausting sometimes.
And just to be able to say it,
it doesn't mean you're not
committed to mentoring,
it doesn't mean you don't want a good job,
but just it's okay to
say that it takes energy
and and you're tired.
I think it encouraged some mentors
to take a minute to look
for signs of burnout
in themselves and others and be honest
about where they are,
but then the answer could be difficult.
And I think when the
answer is, I am burnt out
and I feel like I need to
take a break from mentoring
and I feel like I'm in
a position that I can't
because of who, the consequences,
whether that be political,
whether that be for promotion and tenure
in the academic setting,
whether that be consequential
to the people you're mentoring.
But one of the things we tried
to raise in the article is,
was kind of we didn't call it this,
but it was kinda like if you're faking it.
So if you're trying to mentor from a place
of exhaustion and burnout,
you're probably not doing a good job.
And this was actually couched in a term
by one of the wonderful
mentorship scholars,
Belle Rose Ragins,
who actually called it marginal mentoring,
where you're basically
engaged in dysfunctional
or disengaged mentoring
because you're so depleted.
So you might think, fine,
I'll meet with all seven of my mentees.
But if you're really doing that
from a place of exhaustion,
there's consequences to that
in terms of the kind
of mentorship you are.
And I think that was the other thing
that we really got some
interesting feedback on
was the permission and suggestion
to talk about burnout with your mentees,
to normalize that conversation
that there are imperfections,
if you don't wanna call
it, there's normalcy,
there's coping, there's avoiding.
And that when mentors
continue to try to model
that they never get burnt
out and they're never tired,
the mentees begin to believe
they cannot do that job.
Because they'll say,
I'll never be able to do that
without saying I'm tired sometimes.
So I think that was one piece
we wanted to give people
and the encouragement to be
realistic and honest about,
there's ups and downs, there's burnout,
there's exhaustion,
and model how to do it.
Model as a mentor of saying,
I can't meet with you this week.
It's not because I don't care,
it's because I actually
probably won't be helpful
'cause I'm just burnt out.
And that being okay.
I mean obviously there's content,
people can be in crisis.
We're not saying like
someone's in crisis and saying,
I can't help you, at least to
refer them to someone else,
but in the day-to-day.
And I think back to that there's risk
of just pushing through as a mentor.
So I think those were some of the things
in terms of feedback.
And I think you're right.
I mean for some folks we
don't wanna think about it.
or mentors say, well yeah that's nice,
but I'm trapped.
I'm not a big,
I remember all the way back to high school
is one of my most influential teachers,
one of the exercises they would do
is that whenever you were feeling trapped,
they said you had to come up
with at least three approaches
to the situation you were in.
You could not only come up with two.
And I always think back to that
because I think when we feel trapped,
the exercise of saying how could I get out
or how could I change it,
is to try to think beyond
one or two options.
Now that's also contextual.
So I know one of the things
that we can talk about
in a little bit is not
everybody gets asked
the same amount of service
work or mentorship.
Not everybody has the
ability to have folks help.
Some folks have a lot of
additional family help,
they have access to money
that they can throw out
the problem.
Folks will be like, you're burnt out.
Just go on a spa vacation.
Well that's not accessible
to a lot of people
for a lot of reasons.
And that's lovely if you can do that,
but that's probably not an answer
that's gonna really resonate
with a lot of people
who feel like that's
completely inconsiderate
of inequity and access
to those kind of things.
Taking a walk, it's a
little bit different.
Believing you don't have
five minutes to walk
because you feel so crunched
and saying to somebody,
I really wanna encourage
you to just take a moment
and hear what you're saying,
that you don't have five minutes.
That makes me sad that you feel that way
so let's talk about why you feel that way.
But yeah, so I think the,
an article like this
triggers all of those things.
- I mean there's so many layers there
and just the way that you've
brought all those to light,
even as you were talking
about the modeling
as we talked about from
the beginning, mentoring
well from learning from either
good models or poor models
and just the way that
acknowledging that burnout
can be such an example I think is huge.
But then even all the other
pieces that you mentioned
as well and a lot to unpack there,
but just the guilt that
comes with that sometimes,
the perfectionism that
come with that sometimes.
But then even the
inequities as you mentioned
and all the complexity
that comes with that
topic that I'm sure,
and I know you all touched on as well,
is the mentor as well and
whether it's a female mentor,
whether it's someone from
an underrepresented group,
and the additional burden that comes
just in conversations that
I've had with so many people
in personal experience of knowing that
some of our mentees feel like
they can't go to anybody else,
which then adds another layer of guilt
in the sense that we can think
if we don't mentor this person, who will?
And there is truth to
that to some extent, too,
but then how much that can
also lead towards that burnout.
So I appreciate the way
that you brought that up
in the article.
And I'm just curious
if there's anything you'd
want to expand on that,
on that tension, that real
tension that's there as well?
Because obviously you
can also get to a point,
as you mentioned, of mentoring so many
that you become ineffective.
So I know there's no perfect,
there is no perfect
answer, but how have you,
have you all at least described that
and how have you been thinking
about some of those...
- Yeah, and I don't know that,
when you're writing a short article for,
for a publication like
Harv Business Review,
you're gonna get crunched
and so you can't really
unpack all of that.
You can leave little
breadcrumb trails for that
but I think that's one
of the great things is
you get a lot of people
kind of thinking about it,
a lot of publicity around it,
but you don't get to
really dig into nuance.
And that can rub people
the wrong way, absolutely.
Because you get that sense
like it's not that simple.
And then part of it is
hoping that the authors
know it's not that simple
and we're limited by space.
But also there's sometimes
when authors miss things.
I'm sure we missed things too,
or folks thought, did you not consider?
And there are probably
many thoughts people
had about things that we didn't consider
and is room to grow.
I do think you raise, especially around,
I mean we know, you know,
and I'm sure many of the
guests you've had before know
that individuals from
underrepresented groups,
they get asked to do more of this work.
I mean, let's just more
of the mentorship work.
When we're talking
about academic settings,
we know they're asked to
do more mentorship work,
more equity inclusion,
diversity, justice work,
more psychosocial work.
So there's a huge inequity
about what they're asked to do.
And it's not just what they're
asked to do by leadership,
it's what they're sometimes
articulated and not articulated
expected to do by their peers.
And then what they are asked to do
by folks who feel like they share
certain identities with them.
And even though I think
there is a real call
to white identified folks like myself
to take some of that burden on
and to do the work that's needed
to be more culturally responsive
and to be a more culturally
responsive mentor,
and we do a lot of that type of training,
is at the end of the day,
is there's a lot of mentees that are wary,
that don't trust, have
every right not to trust
that someone like me could hear them
and support them no matter
how much I've prepped.
And at a minimum, even if they believe it,
don't wanna start there.
And so that puts additional burden
on folks like yourself.
And so I know there's a
lot of talk and effort
to make that work valued
and to compensate it,
but again,
no amount of compensation buys you time.
It doesn't buy you
a refill on the emotional drain.
And so I think it should still be done.
I'm a big fan of being
compensated for that work.
And it can't be the only answer
because it can't solve all of the burnout
that is unequally divided amongst people.
- Yeah, that's really well said.
And even as you were talking about it
really resonate with the
not being able to buy time.
But in a way it also made me think about
the experience that you
all had as authors as well,
even just naming that burnout
and just the power that can also come
from having conversations like this,
or for those of us who are
from overlapping backgrounds,
having the space to talk
about that together.
And again, this is just
anecdotal, this is not
evidence-based, but just
as I've been reflecting
on some of the things that you said
and so many other guests have shared
about the work that they
do, just being in the room,
I mean so many people
have come on this podcast
and even made that type of comment
about the conversations they've had here.
Not that it removes the challenges
or the burnout that may come,
but just to be able to
kind of walk through that
and think collectively about ways
to navigate that I think can
be really powerful as well.
- Well and it could be compounded.
we know that one of the things,
that I think one we talked about
when we were working on the article
was data like women physicians
spend on average two minutes more
on each patient than men
and are more likely to
explore the socio-emotional
and psychosocial issues during the visit.
And I know Brad Johnson
had referred to that
in some of his earlier work.
So it feels like just two minutes,
but two minutes and the type
of emotional work over time,
across a day, across a week, across a year
It takes a toll and it's not equal.
I think the other thing
about burnout too is
I have a lot of,
feel very honored that
I have a lot of friends
and colleagues who will
challenge me, call me out.
And I remember one colleague saying,
this was way before we
worked on the article,
but I remember saying something like,
oh, I'm just feeling so
burnt out on all this work.
And she knew I acknowledged
there was inequity
and who held work and all of that,
but it was this kind of
off the cuff comment,
but it has sat with me
and I think there's so much power in it.
And she is a Black identified
individual and she said,
I've felt burnt out.
You feel burnout right now,
I feel burnout every week of every day
for my entire career.
And I just had to stop.
And even think about folks
talking about burnout,
wanting to honor their burnout,
but also calling people to
contextualize their burnout.
Even burnout has privilege
in that we've had episodic burnout
as opposed to consistent burnout.
And I think those are just things, again,
I wanna honor the individual
experience and not
devalue anyone saying they feel burnout.
That's not my intent.
But I think it's important
for us to realize
that even in our speaking into the space,
we are not all talking about
the same level of burnout,
the same causes of burnout
or the frequency at
which we're feeling it.
- Yeah.
I think that's really well said as well.
And just, again.
- I have no idea what it would feel like
to feel burnt out my entire career
every single month of my career.
That is an absolute foreign concept to me
'cause I've had the
privilege not to feel it.
- But even in hearing
that challenging story,
part of me feels
encouraged that you all had
the space to have that conversation.
And then as you've mentioned,
even with the article itself too,
like there's just such a need
to be able to unpack that.
I think like in that context,
even if it's, let's say there were two
other individuals who are
having that same conversation
to be able to then delve in
and really understand what that means.
So much learning that
can happen from that.
And the learning obviously isn't enough
in and of itself,
but again, it just seems like it creates
this opportunity in a sense.
And maybe not being too optimistic,
but just to have community in that sense
to be able to share those
two different experiences,
even you saying, I can't imagine
what that would feel like to have someone
voice that to you and
then to have a dialogue.
I think there's a lot of power
that comes from that as well.
- Yeah.
It can be such a scary space
and it's where the most
amazing learning is happening.
Which is why I'm so
appreciative you're doing
the podcast series because
it creates space for that.
I was saying before we started,
I was really so loving
the experiment in you
being accommodating of the schedules
of myself and Dr. Ireland.
And I would've loved to
been on the same space,
but the fact you had put us together
got me really thinking
about my faith,
my Christian upbringing,
what's the narrative in my
head and heart about service
and being a servant and
being selfless and burnout.
And so I'm really excited to hear
the whole podcast world together,
to hear thoughts on that.
But I really, I've really spent
a couple weeks, not consistently,
but since your invitation wrestling around
the messaging and my
belief that we are called,
in my Christian faith and in other faiths,
but I can only speak from my lived faith,
to embrace service to the
point of selflessness.
And that we're,
the narrative that's written
is that that will fulfill you.
That you will gain energy from that.
But then I know that if you give
to the point of collapse,
it serves no one.
And so just sitting in that paradox,
for lack of a better word,
I don't have an answer, but I've realized
I haven't reconciled those
and this you brought up the word guilt,
and I've been of late,
been working with a really
wonderful leadership coach
in the last year and I,
you're probably not surprised,
I totally subscribe to servant leadership.
But as our work has grown,
I have realized that that
can't be my only approach
because it's actually impossible
'cause I can't be in service to everyone
and just keep it growing.
There becomes a limit.
And so I have, I'm having to
change my leadership style
and I feel a little guilty about it.
So yeah, you're saying yes,
like you've been, so I'd love
to hear your thoughts on this too and,
but I hadn't considered how wrapped up
that struggle was in my faith
and this has really
afforded me the opportunity
and to really think about that
because of the pairing you
put together for the podcast.
I don't think I would've
gone there in my thinking.
But I'm curious like, yeah, you had
a very interesting look on your face
so I'm really curious what
you're thinking right now.
- Yeah, you definitely picked up on it.
And partially, I mean, before we wrap up,
I'm gonna also ask you
if you have any particular
question you'd like me to pose
to Dr. Ireland as you've been
thinking through this as well.
But I can definitely
relate in a lot of ways,
even going back to when you were asking
early on for me to think about times
when I felt burnt out
or even when you were doing
the check-in early on.
So that's part of the conversations
that's come up in my
leadership coaching as well,
specifically around mentorship.
So thinking about how that
has shifted over the years
as I've gotten more and more involved
in different groups and
different initiatives.
I mean full disclosure,
whenever I tell people what I do,
not even on a daily basis
but just in general, people
always ask me if I sleep,
that's always the next
question that comes up,
which is an important question.
But it also means that I can't be involved
in mentoring the same
way I was 13 years ago
when I started the lab
or scale to do things
that I've done now.
And even I even share this
as I'm mentoring others in
leadership positions too.
Sometimes I have to make
difficult decisions about
do I take this one-on-one
mentoring opportunity here
or do I take an opportunity
to go speak to a group
of 50 people at once?
And that it's not a numbers thing per se,
but there's also an effectiveness.
And I don't wanna call it efficiency,
but it doesn't feel like the
right tone for mentorship,
But also like how much can
I get this information out
to people who need it?
So even in the leadership
coaching that I've been having,
having those feelings of guilt
and being coached and told
that those are gonna come
and I basically just have to ride them out
because I can either
try to address the guilt
and continue doing things
the way I was before
and move towards a deeper
phase of being burnt out.
Or I can be wise about it,
try to spread things out,
try to nominate and have
others step into those roles to
limit some of my
mentorship, which feels bad.
And there's guilt that comes with that
because sometimes there
are really important needs.
So I think I'm right there.
And you could sense
that as you were sharing
that I'm right there in the middle of that
and trying to think about that.
Even going all the way
back to the first question
you asked about the check-in
'cause even right now
I'm starting to write
a book proposal and doing
those types of things.
I have to be very disciplined
in setting aside time
to do that or it's never going to happen,
which means I have to say no
to some mentorship opportunities,
some other opportunities.
So just in the middle of all
those pieces simultaneously.
So a lot that I can relate to,
which you very well picked up on
in my nods.
But it's an ongoing process,
and as you've talked about too,
it's a learning process.
So I'm still learning as I go through.
And just trying to be open with people
about those yeses and nos
even though they're not easy.
- Yeah, it is a journey.
Yeah, and I would love
to hear Dr. Ireland.
What advice or what experiences
have they had in
coping with the emotional
part of saying nos
to people who are in need,
even if you know
that that no is completely justified,
is the right thing in terms of priorities
and impact and self-care?
There's a cost with saying no.
And maybe there isn't to everyone.
I don't know actually.
I don't know if that, if I feel that
because of my upbringing,
because of my faith,
because I haven't queried it until now.
And so I'd be really curious
because clearly they have to say no
to people in need to be able
to succeed and survive in those heavy,
compassionate care jobs.
And yet how do you deal with that?
Because as you said, so you decide
to give the talk to 50
and it might turn out
that 3 people of those 50,
it is incredibly impactful
and meaningful and it's the right choice.
And then the one-on-one
mentee you said no to
might feel, you know, not that it's
irreversible, but might
temporary feel abandoned.
Or that they're not a priority,
and in that decision,
they were not a priority.
And that doesn't mean it isn't justified,
but that's such a struggle in terms of
how to feel about that.
- Yeah.
I hundred percent agree.
- So still the cause to think through it.
I'd also love to hear just about
the encouragement that I suspect
is that we're not doing it alone.
And even
many of our faith leaders
now and in the past,
whatever your belief,
there are stories across all religions
about people in those roles,
whether it's Jesus or whomever,
being fed, being cared for, resting,
being washed, being supported,
literally in the case of Christian faith,
carrying the cross for
to take the burden off for a while.
And I've been thinking a lot about that
in the sense of how
often when we get burnt out we
narrow our circle
and we go internal,
and it's when we need support the most.
Whether it's just some perspective
or it's just somebody to take a little bit
of the burden off
but we tend to isolate
when we feel burnt out.
- Wow, that's really well said.
You did say you're not a psychologist,
but you did say you have a
mother who's a therapist.
- My mother is a family therapist.
Yes, definitely.
And in full disclosure, we've had a lot of
mental health challenges
across the whole family
and have had what I feel is a privilege
to talk about it.
It's hard to cope when you
literally cannot do something
because your body or your
mind tell you you cannot.
And needing to accept help and yeah.
So anyway, I'm not in
my area of expertise,
but putting these two topics together
made me think a lot about
I'm really curious in
the pastoral care realm.
How these kinds of
questions are thought about
and reflected on.
I'm sure there will be no answers,
just like there's no answers for
how we make every decision
around our role as mentors,
but to your point earlier,
but that were being
reflective and intentional
in those decisions.
Because at least you
have an answer for why.
Somebody might challenge your why,
but at least you have a why.
- And the other thing that,
as you're sharing is
really jumping out to me
is just again the importance of community.
And my listeners have
heard me say that a lot,
but even as you were talking about
just how easy it is to
become very narrow in focus
and the importance of community
to bring those outside
perspectives sometimes
or to help us to pause and see things
from a different perspective.
Even as you talked about,
if someone is in a place of burnout,
having someone in community to help them
kind of think about
where that's happening.
I mean, the way that you were doing that
even as we were talking and how important
that could be as well.
And my anticipation would be
even in talking with Dr. Ireland,
the importance of that
community for him as a leader
of leaders and helping other leaders
to remember to have those
bigger perspectives.
'Cause I know he's also done boot camps
for pastoral staff and helping them
think through some of those pieces about,
I would imagine even though
they're focused on others,
it can be easy to be isolated and
driven in that focus to
not have enough perspective
from outside.
So I think it's gonna
be a great conversation.
I'll be curious maybe we'll,
I'll try have him respond to some
of these questions as well.
Unfortunately he won't be
able to ask you questions
that you could then respond to,
but perhaps we'll create some type of
other way for that to happen as well.
But I think that's gonna be really.
- It would only be fair, right?
So you brought up something
that's really interesting
that I've been thinking
about a lot too is,
so you said, do people
ask you, do you sleep?
And I think this is a question of things
we don't talk about either and actually
is probably one of the
most important things
in terms of self-care.
So I'll answer if you answer.
Do you sleep?
How much do you sleep?
- I do sleep. So it depends.
I think I've become, maybe this is my age
catching out to me,
more adamant about that
as I've gotten older.
So whereas before I even,
in the last two years when
I started this podcast,
I would tend to let that stuff
kind of go into the night,
whereas now I'm trying
to be more particular
about just having a shut off time.
And again, this may be the
age, but I've just also,
in the spirit of what
we've been talking about,
just paying attention when we
talk about paying attention
to things like burnout,
paying attention to
how much less effective
I am as the day goes on.
And then just realizing
if I just leave that,
I'm gonna feel behind,
but I'm gonna do it five times faster
if I come back to it the
next day more refreshed.
So part of my, I think
getting sleep is also,
again, this goes back to the guilt.
I don't like leaving
things feeling undone,
but allowing myself to say, that's fine
and that will actually help me
still get the rest I need
and will actually help
me be more efficient
and maybe refreshed and
think through things
more carefully when I come back to it.
So I'd say that's kind of my experience.
It's not perfect yet.
There are family
responsibilities and activities
and all those things that throw sleep
out the window often.
Not completely, but you know,
you could always have more.
But I'd say from that standpoint,
better than I would've expected.
I think if I didn't get that,
I'd actually probably be in
a place of being burnt out
and have to take away one
of the many components
that I'm involved in at the moment.
- Yeah, I hear you on that.
My husband says sleeping is my superpower.
So I do sleep, I can sleep anywhere.
And when I'm up, I'm up.
And when I'm done, I'm done.
- That's good.
- And I am,
I've had to grapple with
I am a less,
I would've used the word crabby
when I don't sleep or if
I don't tend to my sleep.
But it is more that I am not as kind
as I wanna be when I don't sleep.
And somehow being honest
with myself about that
made me be able to
prioritize it even more.
Is there something about
if I say to myself,
not just so I love like what you're saying
is like letting it go till the next day
'cause I'll do it more efficiently
and more effectively.
I'm on your train on that one.
And saying if you choose to stay up,
you're probably gonna have meetings
in which you're not as kind
as you would strive to be.
And then you have to own that.
And so anyway, I'm still
working on that too.
But that narrative to me
has been very interesting
in terms of motivation.
- That's really helpful. Yeah.
And again, just the level of honesty
that you're willing to
have with yourself as well.
- But then it makes me even more,
you know, my children are both grown now,
but oh man, when they're little
and you don't have any power
over the sleep you're getting
and just trying to make it and
or if you have other
family responsibilities
is so much empathy for that stage of life.
It is challenging.
- Yeah, and I had forgotten that
until I had been around family members
with young kids again
and it took me back then,
I didn't know how I'd forgotten that.
Well again, just really appreciate,
just your honesty with so
many different aspects.
I'm gonna venture a guess to say
that this is not a typical conversation
that you have on a daily basis
in your work in terms of the
things that we've spanned.
But I really appreciate.
You want us to be able
to kind of think through
and wrestle with those two.
And even as you've brought
up the faith aspect,
and that's something that's
definitely near and dear
to me and to what we try
to do on this podcast
just to have deep, honest conversations
about all aspects of our lives
and not get stuck in this
kind of compartmentalizing
and pretending that there
are aspects of our lives
that exist, whether we come from
a faith perspective or not.
So I really appreciate your willingness
and we'll definitely pass
some of those questions
along as well.
One last question I did
want to ask you though
comes from our listeners
and particularly because people
were so excited about
this topic of burnout.
So one of our listeners asked how
to avoid or at least deal with burnout,
and this is specifically
within academic context,
but it expands elsewhere as well.
But just as people kind
of get more and more roles
and responsibilities
with career development
and achievement and things like that,
and I won't call it the prom,
but the challenge of people who seem
to be doing things well
and then seem to get more
and more added onto their plate.
And just knowing how to navigate that.
I don't know if you
have any specific words
of wisdom you wanna share there.
- Yeah, so I mean I do,
I think I'm gonna come back to
kind of what I started
to share in the journey
of even writing the piece.
And then what I've noticed
in my own practice is,
and it might sound simple,
but is really, and I'll use
the word querying burnout.
I was listening to and I,
embarrassed to say I don't remember
what podcast it was.
But don't worry, I will never
forget that it's this podcast.
But I realized the irony
in me saying that as I,
I listened to something
and I didn't remember whose it was.
So sorry to that person, but
it was really interesting.
It was about someone who
had a very, very high,
high pressure job
leadership position and
just felt so burnt out
that they just left.
That's it.
And then in this person's
story, they went on,
they actually, I think they went and lived
on an island actually.
if I'm remembering it right.
And poor person, if they've
ever listened to this,
is gonna think I'm completely
slaughtering their story
so I apologize.
but the basic idea was
completely burnt out,
decided the only answer
was to completely remove themselves.
Went and basically did nothing
and had the opportunity to do that,
most of us can't do that,
but then missed everything
about their work.
And I only raised it because
some of the reflections
then that came back,
they did then end up
being going back to work
and was that it wasn't all
the things on their list,
it was perspective.
They actually loved most
of the work they did.
It actually energized
them a lot of the time.
They liked their colleagues
and working with them.
They were passionate about
doing something meaningful.
But it had all gotten a bit much,
they couldn't prioritize,
they couldn't focus.
It was all just too much.
And the inability to
have perspective on it
just seemed like the
only thing you could do
was to just lead.
And I think we've all been there,
when we look at everything we
feel we're being asked to do
or we even feel compelled to do
and we go, it's impossible.
And I think that the querying of it
in the burnout is saying, okay,
it is probably impossible.
So I could go the extreme
and do none of it,
that has consequences,
or I can think about which
pieces I'm gonna do or not.
And then obviously, like
you said in community
start to query that and what is draining?
What is sustaining?
How are those balanced?
And so I really do think, especially
if we're talking about junior colleagues
in academia who see this
place that they have to get to
in order to be promoted
and it feels so high impact
and so high stakes.
And then all of the other
things are being asked to do
and compelled to do and starting to query
about what sustains, what burns out,
what's gonna pay out, what's not,
and to not do that alone.
I think when we do that alone,
everything about our own
biases or all our habits,
they all play out.
And sometimes like we, it's interesting,
we both talk about coaches,
someone reflecting back,
and you've probably had
this experience back,
if they reflected back
and you go, oh, right.
So actually what you've heard me saying
is there's really one major priority
that I wanna get done this month
and I should spend time on that.
And then suddenly it's clear,
but I couldn't see it myself.
So that may be to your listeners
feel like way too straightforward,
but I feel like
examining ourselves is sometimes
the best thing to do.
And if you feel like it is
impossible without burning out,
it probably is.
But that doesn't mean you can't get help
to find make some choices.
But it's back to that trapped feeling,
and the drowning feeling
that becomes terrifying.
And to go back to having somebody
walk you through and say,
if you are feeling trapped and burnt out,
let's come up with seven possible ways
that that could maybe
be a little different,
and maybe one of those
will be worth trying.
Not just one way.
You quit and go to an island.
It was kind of like,
that is an option maybe,
for a lot of people, not an option.
But I think it's so much about perspective
and I think, I'll be curious
what Dr. Ireland says
and I think that
if you have belief in a certain faith
or even if you don't believe
in a certain religion,
but whatever your beliefs are about
what is valued, what's important,
what those communities can do for you
is to give perspective.
And I think at the end of the day,
that's often what we're most afraid of,
but we're most seeking.
Is just a different perspective
'cause we're trapped in
our own head and heart.
- I hundred percent agree.
I think that's a really helpful answer
even if it feels straightforward just,
and I think, as people listen to this,
they will have that experience
of what you just mentioned too.
Just hearing it,
even though you're not speaking with them
in direct conversations,
just having that reflective moment
I think will be really important.
- so my husband does for me,
I always say he's my best partner because,
and I know we're ending up so I'll just,
I'll tell a little funny anecdote.
So I'll come home sometimes and
like many I'll complain about everything
that everybody's asked me to do
and how things are unfair
and I'm being blocked off everywhere.
Everything I try to do
is blocked by someone
or the system and you know,
we've all been there.
The world's against us.
And I'll say, I can't, you know,
I don't know if I can do
all this work in this job.
And he'll listen and he'll
say, that sounds hard.
And then he'll say, let me remind you,
every day, you get to go to a job
that you feel like is making
a difference in the world.
That people listen to you
and sometimes think you have good ideas,
that you have some power,
it's not as much as you
want, but you have privilege.
And he'll just run the list and he'll say,
and of course in doing it,
he's not trying to not validate it,
he's trying to just give some perspective.
And and I go, you are,
and I always say, yes,
I'm still frustrated,
but yeah, I forgot about that.
And so for me, and that
doesn't work for everyone
and I know that can be triggering
and obviously not everyone feels
like someone's gonna be able to say,
and here's all your privilege,
because not everybody goes to
a job where they feel heard
and that the work they do
is meaningful and valued.
But for most faculty,
to get to where they are,
you have been hired because people believe
you have something to contribute.
You have taken that job because you feel
like you have something to give
that's gonna change the world,
that's gonna have impact.
And that alone is an amazing opportunity.
Yeah, the system stinks
and lots has to change
and it's not fair and it's not equitable.
But for the folks in the academy,
there are certain beautiful things
about the opportunities to
work in a space like that.
It needs a lot of work,
but it does offer a
pretty amazing opportunity
to do that work.
- Yeah. Highly agree.
And again, just the
importance of community
to be able to remind each other of that
the way your husband has done
and to be able to celebrate those things
as they happen.
I mean, so many ways I've
seen communities rise.
- Look at your job, you
get to do a podcast.
I mean, it's amazing
that this gets to be part
of your work and your mission
is just an amazing thing.
- I do feel honored,
blessed, and privileged
in that sense as well.
And it's such a reminder to me.
I mean, everything you just shared
as guests have come on
and shared that with me,
as listeners have continued to share that,
even people who've found this podcast
through different means.
I mean, even meeting with
someone this week who said,
oh, I just saw this pop
up into my YouTube feed
and was able to share just the ways
that the podcast has
really encouraged them.
So again, as you've mentioned,
that privilege and that
perspective is huge.
In some ways I feel like I've been,
I've been using this
podcast to facilitate more
of these conversations because
I come away so encouraged
from these types of things as well.
And for me, I would even say this past,
I can't even track anymore,
it's been two years,
almost two years in the podcast
has been so helpful for
that perspective as well.
And just that frequent reminder.
And then again, seeing
people who are invested
in so many different
areas and walks of life
I think is really,
just really, really touching.
I don't even know if I can
put words into it per se
as you're actually helping me reflect.
And I think just projecting it forward,
projecting it onto
listeners who are tuning in,
even for those for me of us
who have felt feelings of burnout
or getting too close, trying to pull back,
I think the perspective is huge.
And again, it goes back
to what we talked about
I think at the beginning of this recording
and just the place that we
both seem to be at this moment.
Being able to be excited and reflective
and being able to hold onto that
even when the busyness comes.
So I appreciate you sharing that story
from your husband that, I mean
that's part I'm gonna go
back and listen to again,
just the way that he,
I like how he said that people
sometimes listen to you.
'Cause I think, I mean
that's part of it as well
that's that mixture.
- It's not always.
- But even that sometimes
it's still important.
- It's still, yeah.
It's such a, I mean, and
I think on this topic of
I know it's burnout but mentorship is,
it's hard as the work can be
and as tiring it can be,
and we don't want mentors to be burnout,
mentorship is just the most
amazing privileged work
to be able to influence someone's life
one-on-one like that, it's amazing.
- Well said.
And a great parallel to Dr.
Ireland coming up as well.
- Yes, can't wait to hear his thoughts.
So wonderful.
- Well thank you so much for being here.
Thank you for the work that you do.
Thank you for taking time to share
So honestly and openly here and just,
and practically as well.
I know that people are really gonna enjoy
listening to this and I
hope this will also generate
some conversation in communities
as we've talked about already today.
So Dr. Pfund, thank you again.
I've really enjoyed hosting you.
- Thanks for the opportunity.
(upbeat techno music)